four words Ferris Bueller's Day Off
arguably the best movie to come out of
the 80s
Bueller every kid dreams of being Ferris
they think he's a righteous dude and who
could forget that red Ferrari an
unforgettable scene with an
unforgettable soundtrack and that music
is thanks to the Swiss duo known as
yellow hi I'm Boris Blanc and D de Meyer
we are yellow we've been together for
more than 40 years I'm responsible for
the composition of the band yellow and
I'm the voice the lyricist oh yeah I was
just a track on our album Stella at the
time back in 1985 I start with a funky
bass line a pen I add as usual some drum
patterns and then I add some voice
percussion which sounds like this
bow-bow bow-bow and then I was
absolutely not inspired by this song I
didn't like it at all but then Boris
told me stories that you imagined you're
the king of Tonga
the Sun is about to go down some people
bring you the perfect great drink the
cool breeze comes to you and in this
situation what would you say when I said
oh this was the birth of the song
the question isn't what are we going to
do the question is what aren't we going
to do
Ferris Bueller's Day Off faded
incredibly big it became like almost a
hymn in the American movie world I think
every kid remembers to get daft if
someone would have told me almost 35
years ago that oh yeah would still exist
in 2020 I wouldn't believe it and of
course it's a very nice thing to have a
hit especially with a very funny and
uniquely limited song like oh yeah
[Music]